angela merkel una de las mujeres más
poderosas del planeta se ha convertido
en un referente para las alemanas
en prenzlauer berg un barrio burgués de
berlín se suele votar a la izquierda
pero para estas jóvenes que han crecido
con la canciller merkel rompió el techo
de cristal es una mujer fuerte soberana
que supo hacerle frente sólo el hecho de
llegar a ser canciller nos demostró que
todo lo podemos como mujeres haitianas
por no obstante realmente ha contribuido
merkel a la causa feminista
las alemanas son cada vez más numerosas
en la fuerza laboral pero un 18% las
separa del salario de los hombres se
tuvo que llegar a 2020 para que como
canciller aceptara una cuota femenina
los consejos de administración de las
grandes empresas un balance tibio según
la federación de emprendedoras alemanas
nos gustaría que las mujeres estuvieran
mejor representadas en la política a la
sociedad y las empresas porque es un
factor de atracción importante por lo
general cuando se compara el sistema de
guarderías de francia con el de alemania
aún queda trabajo por hacer
primera mujer canciller de alemania
merkel no ha motivado cambios sociales
significativos de acuerdo a su biografía
se ha contentado con acompañar a las
mujeres y no fue hasta el fin de su
mandato que se reivindicó como feminista
tras todo este feminismo que emergió de
europa del oeste y en alemania del oeste
siempre le fue ajeno a menudo llegó a
decir que no quería jactarse de los
méritos de esas mujeres que lucharon
desde los años 60 cuando ella no llegó a
participar de esa lucha ni de sus
debates con joni mitchell lipton en sus
16 años en el poder merkel jamás hizo
bandera de su feminidad ni de su
feminismo pese a ello se mantendrá como
un icono para las mujeres del mundo